how do you avoid procrastination I'm
gonna answer that question in today's
episode of ask Evan
so recently God asked the question for
one of my loyal youtube viewers love you
guys
video orchard who wrote in this a great
video bro can you make a video on how to
avoid procrastination I think if there
was ever group that needed help with the
across the nation its entrepreneurs it
can be hard to stay motivated to stay on
task to keep following your goals when
you're doing everything yourself so I'm
gonna share my three ways on how you can
stay motivated and avoid procrastination
number one is have goals that excite you
I'm a big believer in what Anthony
Robbins said when he said that people
aren't lazy they just have goals that
are impotent they have goals that don't
excite them and so if you feel like
you're sluggish in the morning and
you're not motivated to go do something
have a goal that that is exciting for
you have a goal that you want to wake up
and go and accomplish and my big goal is
I want to help a billion entrepreneurs
that gets me excited to get me motivated
gets me out of bed makes me want to go
out and start killing more videos for
you guys so you want to have a big goal
that gets you excited number two commit
to someone else when you commit to
somebody else you're much more likely to
follow through whatever goal you set for
yourself and so as an example I'm making
these YouTube videos for you guys right
I usually do it on a Wednesday I film
all my videos on a Wednesday afternoon
and it'd be easy for me to wake up one
day see I'm not feeling motivated I
don't want to go out and film but now I
have a cameraman who's helping me with
my videos named Jason he's behind the
camera and I said I said Jason come at
12 o'clock we're gonna start filming
right he came over I gotta be ready
right I've committed to him that I'm
gonna follow through on this goal and
when you commit to somebody else you're
much more likely to follow through on
your goal as well so find an
accountability partner you know as
entrepreneurs it can be really hard
because you're not accountable to
anybody but yourself so whether you're
telling your friends your family your
you know your parents loved ones you set
up a mastermind group you set up a
accountability buddy
whatever it is account yourself to
somebody else have a buddy to help you
through your process and you're much
more likely to follow through on your
goals
number three is create a morning routine
this is a huge thing
for entrepreneurs because you could be
on fire one day and a pocket will just
fall in the channel you're on fire one
day you're all excited you're making
huge progress and then the next day you
wake up and you have to start all over
from scratch
and you've lost the motivation you don't
know where to get it and so I like
creating the morning routine that
inspires me that motivates me that gets
me ready for my day and so you want to
think about things that build you up
that inspire you that's why I started
the end special series was to have
entrepreneurship in my blood that little
shot every morning to get me excited
create a routine that is designed on
purpose instead of maybe accidentally
getting motivated by watching some video
at four o'clock in the afternoon create
a morning routine that serves you that
builds you out that makes you want to go
and do something great so remember have
goals that excite you commit to someone
else and create a morning routine and
believe thank you guys so much for
watching I'd love to know how you avoid
procrastination leave it in the comments
below I'm going to join in the
discussion and look forward to hearing
from you soon okay so remember I forgot